zwischen werten an junge männer wie er
einst einer war mit bildung kann man
vieles erreichen
bei jungen menschen beinahe alles auch
das falsche verführung zum hass wie in
diesen videos des sogenannten
islamischen staates öffentlich
vorgeführt auf einem platz in syrien dem
ds eingenommen hat der es streitet nicht
einmal ab diese jugendlichen mit
propagandavideos zu kindersoldaten und
selbstmordattentätern abzurichten
aufgewachsen in einem palästinensischen
ort in israel ist auch ahmad mansour von
solchen seelenfänger verführt worden
und sagt heute rückblickend dass er
selbst einmal islamist gewesen sein
ich war damals 13 ich wurde gemobbt ich
war streber und da auf der suche nach
sozialer kontakte
das hat mein arabischer lehrer der auch
im arm war erkannt und mich angesprochen
deshalb bin ich auch sehr gerne zu
seinen koran unterricht gegangen die
ersten monaten waren harmlos und dann
wurde eigentlich aus tiefe besucher ein
ideologie ideologie des hasses darum
geht andere menschen abzuwerten wo es
darum ging menschen sozusagen von in
allen leben retten zu wollen
ach wat mansoor ist den fängen seines
imams damals entkommen hat psychologie
studiert und setzt heute seine erfahrung
in berlin ein solchen seelenfänger
paroli zu bieten
dabei helfen ihm die heros wahrhaftige
helden des alltags junge menschen die
den mut haben radikalen glaubenssätzen
kritisch zu begegnen und jugendlichen
aus traditionell religiösen familien
unbequeme fragen zu stellen
wir haben eine generation von
jugendlicher die zu hause nicht gelernt
haben kritisch zu denken zu hinterfragen
viele von denen kommen aus
patriarchalische kulturen wo der vater
zu sagen hat der familienoberhaupt wo er
kein zweifel zulässt und solche zustände
natürlich fordern der kritisches denken
nicht und deshalb sind sie auch anfällig
für andere die kalibrierung die
behaupten die absolute wahrheit zu
besitzen
auch die attentäter von paris sharif und
sicorschi sind durch einen salafisten
radikalisiert worden
das löst bei mir traurigkeit das lust
bei mir hilflosigkeit und manchmal auch
das unter und solche menschen auch so zu
sagen gibt
aber ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass
wir wenn wir sozusagen die richtige
instrumente finden wir die richtige
projekte fordern dass wir viele viele
viele jugendliche retten konnten die
vielleicht noch nicht radikal sind aber
vielleicht in der zukunft radikal werden
radikale varianten des islams haben
besonders große chancen in migrantischen
milieus
dort gehen salafisten auf seelen fahren
bieten den jugendlichen zuflucht
akzeptanz orientierung nicht jedoch
selbstständiges denken wir brauchen auch
die schulen damit sie diese jugendliche
in kritisches denken beibringen damit
sie ihnen zum nachdenken bringen damit
sie ihnen alternativen zeigen damit
träume geschafft werden wo die
jugendliche ihre meinung sagen können
diskutieren konnte das ist unfassbar
wichtig und da brauchen wir eine neue
bildungsprojekte wochen eigentlich eine
art von revolution ahmad mansour
arbeitet für heuer eine beratungsstelle
gegen radikalisierung und wurde 2014 für
sein engagement in der jugendarbeit mit
dem moses mendelssohn preis des berliner
senats ausgezeichnet ich arbeite mit
jugendlicher die aussteigen wollen und
versucht sie zu unterstützen und zu
beraten
ich arbeite mit eltern die
bei aktiver projekt das leben eigentlich
heißt wo wir eltern beraten
die ihre kinder sich radikalisiert haben
versuchen die eltern sozusagen
instrumente zu geben damit sie gegen die
vertikalisierung ihre kinder umgehen
können und das eine indirekte deren die
koalitionsarbeit natürlich schwierig
aber manchmal auch möglich auch in der
schweiz ist ahmad man so ein gefragter
mann
doch es braucht mehr menschen wie ihn
die mit persönlicher erfahrung und
wissen in kampf um die köpfe war